[Musique]
alors me l'a suspendu des réseaux
sociaux est ce que vous comprenez ou pas
tout serait parti d'une publication de
millas d'un vieux dessins qu'elle aurait
fait alors qu'elles étaient en
maternelle un des cinq pains au chocolat
mais selon l'adolescente
quelques minutes plus tard en réactivant
son téléphone elle est tombée sur des
centaines de messages d'insultés voilà
chers et islamophobe qui mérite et je
viole à la hâte en quoi je vois là je
veux qu'on en fait un peu trop avec elle
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
madame sais pas ce que je déplore c'est
le manque de transparence dans l'action
modération twitter tout dire que à
l'heure actuelle on a pas de règles
claires si vous êtes insultant c'est
participer à un raid numérique votre
qu'on sera supprimé et c'est normal en
revanche quelle que soit la personne que
vous êtes si vous êtes victimes de ce
raid numérique on vous protégera de ce
raid numérique combien les modérateurs
chez twitter
tout me pose la question et wes qui sont
ces modérateurs on peut les voir
est-ce qu'ils sont en france mais sans
céder localisé à l'échelle des histoires
ya des millions de tweets c'est très
compliqué mais justement c'est gérable
si on s'en donne les moyens marlène
schiappa quand vous voyez en top tweets
à 14h top tweets un numéro un hashtag
jeu violent
allawi est ce que ça vous dérange pas
malade moi ça me dérange
le motif de suppression des comptes
twitter ça peut pas être est ce que ça
dérange vous pas un membre du
gouvernement voyez ce que je veux c'est
pour ça mais non mais c'est pas légal
exactement exactement c'est la loi ou
c'est pas la loi
c'est la règle ou c'est pas la règle et
le problème c'est que là on sait pas
quelle est la règle et quand on ne sait
pas quelle est la règle elle est à
géométrie variable
vous comprenez que les gens qui sont
bien sûr contre les menaces de mort sur
mila mais qui sont extrêmement foncé est
extrêmement triste de voir en top tweets
en france à 14h37 jeu violent à la non
mais attendez
évidemment c'est aimer c'est offensant
pour tout le monde
le sujet c'est qu'il ya deux questions
différentes 1 la critique de la religion
qui est permise et qui est possible dans
la république française
on peut critiquer même de façon
virulente une religion mais on n'a pas
le droit d'appeler à la haine des
croyants d'appeler à la haine ou à la
discrimination des musulmans de tenir
compte
la finale à bâle à l'aller non mais
violet en fait des liens escalade
moi j'appelle à un moment au calme on
appelle au calme c'est ce qu'il faut
faire redescendre la peinture on peut
pas avoir dans les top tweets des
bagarres entre marge de la la ça c'est
pas possible
toi pour saison à tout respect de chacun
et au fait que chacun y compris twitter
prenne ses responsabilités face à ces
propos mois pour moi c'était un délit
excusez moi on peut pas faire un hashtag
de viol trois petits points c'est
scandaleux et je ne crois pas que l'état
français pour le coup d'état on ne peut
pas écrire une chose pareil c'est pas un
grain de voix là c'est je viole trop
petit bois mais s'est offert deux
minutes un débat juridique il n'y a pas
de jurisprudence sur cette question là
non en fait il ya des gens qui vont
plaider en vous disant ce que vous venez
de dire un avocat pour être exactement
la même chose c'est un crime de geler
quelqu'un c'est un appel au crime est
donc cette fille légal il faut le
condamner
et ce sera sanctionné et des gens vont
vous dirai ce cas là est une personne
matérialiser ou des substances y alizés
qui représente quelque chose auquel cas
ça ne serait pas un appel aux trimestres
je suis tombé à 32 twitter je ne suis
pas je prends mes responsabilités qui
sont celles de faire les lois quand elle
est extrêmement dur extrêmement
virulente extrêmement insultante et
violente envers là toute une communauté
qui est la communauté musulmane je
trouve ça un peu de bizarre de dire
qu'elle a rien fait que c'est une
victime alors ça va pardon mais voilà où
vous n'étiez pas là il ya 20 minutes
vous êtes si le curé autre chose ça
défend systématiquement parce que c'est
un symbole du harcèlement et vous
plusieurs choses hein j'ai dit que moi
j'étais choqué par le fait de dire que
viola là c'est évidemment pas opportun
c'est évidemment choquant c'est damman
très choquant tout ce qu'on veut comme
on l'a dit tout à l'heure mais en tant
que mère je me dis une jeune fille qui
harcelait je suis désolé ouais j'ai
envie de la protéger et ensuite oui bien
sûr mais là c'est devenu un symbole vous
avez tout à fait raison
pourquoi parce qu'elle est menacée de
mort vous rendez compte de la violent
mais elle aussi est ainsi tous les sens
mais si vous le 9 de mort on souhaite
leur suicide ont versé des photomontages
avec du sang évidemment on peut que
soutenir une adolescente qui est en
proie à 100